hello everyone and the first part of the
candidates tournament is over which
means that the seven rounds have been
finished and everyone played a game
against everyone so now everyone is
gonna play another game against everyone
only with the different color of pieces
so this is a round eight and we have
Alexandra Grisha versus Vladimir Kramnik
and now in round one of the candidates
Kramnik defeated Alexandra Greece shook
so now Greek has the white pieces and he
has a nice opportunity to even out the
score and this is a pretty weird game a
weird game by kramnik as you'll see but
before we start with the game let's
let's enjoy some photos as we do have
them here is Greece took probably
writing down his name on his score sheet
here we have another close-up of Greece
shook already already deep in thought
even before the first move here we have
kramnik this all of the photos are
before the game even started probably
going for his lucky pen the one used
when he defeated eleven Iranian and here
we have this is somewhere during the
middle game here we have a circuit
correcting on the left checking up on
his fellow Russian so those were the
photos do hope you enjoy them now let's
see the game Greece shook his white and
he opens with C for the English opening
we have e six the eigen court defense
Knight to c3 and the D 5 D for
transposing into the Queens gambit
declined Knight to f6 and now Knight to
f3
we have c5 III he captures sorry D
captures on c4 Bishop captures on c4 and
now a6 preparing b5 here Bishop to b3
now b v e4 seek after son d4 Knight
captures on d4 and worship to b7 and
here a 5 by Greece choke you don't have
time to grab the pawn on g2 because the
white will simply attack the bishop who
drove g1 and then you lose a piece salt
Knight to e4 castles bagri shook and now
Knight captures on c3
be characters on c3 and Knight to c6
here we have a for threatening to win a
pawn on d5 and here chronic could play a
lot of things
for example capture knight on d4 C
captures and push B for all is well for
black and he can play this position
without any problems but here after this
a for move Kramnik decided to sacrifice
a pawn with Bishop to c5 and okay a
capture some b5 agree to accept upon a
captures and now rook captures an 8
Bishop captures and Knight captures on
b5 so what did Cromley get for his pawn
well for now he does have a his Bishop
error is a bit more active but other
than other than that not much here
castles by kramnik he could have gone
for the immediate knife capture Stanley
5 to win the pawn back and after Queen
captures team capture States again a
perfectly fine position for black but he
decides not to do it after knife capture
zombie 5 he castles we have Queen
captures the Greek immediately exchanges
Queen's rook captures and Bishop f4 now
Bishop Grichuk is protecting his pawn on
e5 h6 preparing g5h for stopping g5 and
Knight to e7
rook to d1 and rook to b8 avoiding the
exchange of rooks attacking the knight
and Bishop behind the night so Bishop to
c4 defending Bishop to c6 attacking the
knight twice and now Knight to d4 and
this is move 22 here the game could have
easily been wrong if cronic decided to
play Knight captures on d4 and after C
captures Knight to f5 attacking the h5h
for pawn and also preparing a double
attack on the d4 pawn so after this is
defended after h5 now rook two before
attacking the bishop and here chronic
would win his pawn back either either
the bishop will move and then he'll pick
up the pawn or the rook will defend the
bishop and then you simply capture the
d4 pawn but he's not interested in this
and this is a already a couple of a
couple of times in the game that chronic
actually I don't know did he try to play
for a win here his position is a bit
more active but not so much active at a
compensate for the extra point
to be able to go for a win but okay he
played Bishop to b4 now h5 now Knight to
f5 is no longer with a tempo nice to d5
and here Bishop captures on d5 so Grisha
gives up one of his bishops and now
Bishop captures on d5
okay now Kramnik does have the bishop
pair and now the compensation for the
pawn is at least equal Bishop to e3 rook
to c8 and now rook to e1 we have Bishop
to c4 Knight to f3 and now Bishop to 8/3
Bishop to d4 and now we can see that
chronic special pair is it's I mean
totally enough to compensate for this
pawn there's no way this pawn will ever
move forward and this Bishop of Greece
shikhandi forest is like it's like a big
point so it's not really possible for
for Greece to win this game unless
unless kramnik once the win his game as
well so Bishop to d3 night study - and
now Bishop to b2 a chronic is activating
those bishops we have nice - f1 and here
R up to c4 of course you can't capture
the pawn and c3 if you capture route to
see one simply pinning the Bishop you
lose the game here so wrote to c4 we
have rook to e3 and now Bishop to f5
Knight the g3 and Bishop all the way
back to h7 and here now chronic did move
his bishops out of the way so now there
actually could be some way to push this
extra pawn but first Grisha would have
to get his King into the game and he he
doesn't want to bring his king all the
way here but he can't go King to f1 if
he tries King to f1 then Bishop to c1
attacking the rook rook has to go down
and now burr to d3 check now you either
have to move the King back or block with
the night if you block with the night
then attacking the rook and then after
rogue d1 rook to a for a very
interesting position where black black
will at least get his pawn back of
course you can't capture the bishop then
rook to e1 this will eat the checkmate
after rook to d1 row capture sandy one
the King has nowhere to go but after
this rook day for move you'd have to
move
proved you won and then simply night
captures I need to look after sandy -
and Bishop captures on h5 we have an
opposite color Bishop endgame nothing
nothing to do here for either side
so after this Bishop to h7 Grisham
doesn't activate which King to have one
he activates with King to h2 he's gonna
go all all around to reach this d2 and
d3 square so Bishop to see one rook
three two and now
Bishop to f4 King to h3 we have worked
to a4 now as the King will move from the
hinge side that maybe rook rook to a2
will be possible to pick up the King
side pawns soaking to g4 Bishop to see
one now King to f3 Bishop to d3 rook to
e1 Bishop to b2 and now King to e3 so
there's really no way of stopping this
King Bishop to see to kink to d2 by
Grichuk
Bishop to b3 and now rook to be one rock
to a - defending King to d3 and now
Bishop to a4 we have Knight to e4 Bishop
to e3 and now King to e3 better to see -
rook to e1 and Bishop back to be three
g4 Bishop to d5 came to d3 Bishop to e7
rook to be one and now rook to e8 and
now f4 and if you look at this position
now compared to the position where all
of Greece rooks pawns were on second
rank and his skin was it wasn't g1 and
chronics bishops were extremely active
now you have this position that would
not have been possible if kramnik wasn't
trying to win his position being a pawn
down and trying to trying to over
activate his bishop pair now you can see
that this pawn structure is is
completely the same and but Grichuk does
have this path C pawn he does have a
more active rockin b1 this night is very
nicely placed firmly can always capture
but that's not going to help him and he
does most importantly he does have an
active King Gandhi 3 so that's pretty
that I mean that's enough resources for
you to convert this extra pawn into
interval point so Bishop 2h
or a rock - h1 a bishop to d8 rook the
be one we have Bishop to c7 and now King
- III King - III Grisha wants to prepare
the pushing of c-4 for but c4
immediately also works so King III King
to h7 Knight to d6 King back to g8 rook
to b5
Bishop to c6 rook to b4 and brush up to
d8 we have Bishop to b6 offering a trade
of bishops bunch of to h4 bishop to d4
bishop to g2 rook to be - Bishop to c6
rook to b6 Bishop to g2 rook to be to
Bishop back to c6 rope to b3 Bishop to
g3 and now finally c4 Bishop to h2 now
comes f5 pawn captures Knight captures
on f5 King to h7 Bishop to b2 we have
rook to e8 Knight to d6 attacking the
rook rook moves to e7 and here rook to
b8 by grisha here
Grichuk is basically offering Kramnik to
pick up his e5 pawn and in fact this
would be the best thing maybe maybe the
last thing kramnik could hope for in
this game would the idea that if Bishop
captures Bishop captures and rook
captures would check King to d4
attacking the rook f6 defending the rook
and now Knight to Knight to f7 this was
the idea threatening checkmate
and here chronic will be forced to play
rook e8 exchange rooks Rock captures
Bishop captures and after Knight to d6
attacking the bishop bishop to c6 and
it's it's very hard to say can could
white actually win this game he does
have a a passed pawn here but Bishop to
f3 could be very dangerous or both of
these phones are on light squares so
obviously I mean probably he knew that
him that he knew that this was a winning
position for white or or maybe he didn't
even see it so it's hard to say if any
of you caught the the interview after
the game
do share in the comments so after rook
to b8 he decided to go f6 immediately
we have rook to see a
and now Bishop to h1 Knight to a5 rook
to b7 and II captures on f6 now with the
idea of course that if you capture the
bishop here you get F garrison g7 and
there's no defense against a rock to h8
so after each captures on f6 rope the b3
check Bishop to c3 and now again you
don't even have the time to capture the
bishop with rook captures on c3 with
check because after ink at the d4 again
you don't have time to move the rook so
you would have to capture here with rook
captures but after King captures simply
G captures left on f6 and white is
completely winning here
so after Bishop to see three G captures
on f6 by chronic and now King to d2
Bishop to f4 check King moves rook to b8
offering a trade of rooks rook captures
Bishop captures and now Knight to e7
we have Bishop to g4 check King d2
Bishop f4 check King to e2 and now you
can see that we took still is up his
extra pawn and once once he manages to
activate his King this point is I'm
gonna decide the game so Bishop King to
g7 Knight to a5 we have king f7 Bishop
to d2 Bishop to e5 or you can exchange
bishops so that doesn't help you either
so Bishop to e5 but this loses the H
pawn Bishop captures on h6 King e6
Bishop back to e3 Bishop captures an ef5
pawn captures and King captures so now
it's 2 points against the pawn and
unfortunately for chronic this is
winning so h6 king g6 we have a c5 f5
King to f3 King to have 7 Bishop to f4
now offering a trade of Bishops of
course you can't accept that we have c6
King to e7 c7 King to d7 now h7 King to
c8 and now King to e2 King to d7 and now
King to d3 and in this position Vladimir
Kramnik finally resigned
game he resigned because there's a very
simple plan for white after you play
something with a bishop as its attacked
you simply bring the King into the game
black has to play something you bring
the King closer and now it's over
whatever whatever black plays Bishop to
e5 and you either exchange this bishop
or the bishop moves and then you pick up
a queen but after the exchange there's
this pawn is simply winning King
captures and you bring a queen into the
game it's all over
so after King to d3 wedding with chronic
resigned the game and a very nice
revenge for Alexander Grichuk so it's
very interesting what was a chronic
trying to achieve this entire game he he
refused the draw like at least three or
four times and is it I mean it's either
maybe he maybe he thinks that he's such
a better player than Greece shock that
he can actually beat him at that
position or I don't know what was what
was he trying to achieve you know man
maybe because he's the he's the lucky
card in this tournament so maybe he
doesn't feel like he needs to actually
achieve anything but yeah it's a it's a
shame because he he definitely had a
great start to this tournament
especially with that win against Aragon
in round 3 but yeah and before I forget
here are the results so far in this
tournament after round 8 here we have
Caruana still in first place with five
and a half points then my mayara win
second would have a point less then
Greece Chuku after his win against
Kramnik here in round 8 of would four
and a half points out of eight then
being we were and then kramnik then
Carrick and then Aragon and worsley so
both of them with three points so six
more rounds till the end of this
tournament a lot of things could happen
I mean even even so an argument could
still win it if they if they win all of
the other games so you never know we'll
just have to wait and see so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it
chronic sure meets a couple of weird
decisions I would like to thank David
Orban ski Alexander Shaffer John Dylan
better named Strom Petrov Inga
Alexander Alexandrov and Douglas rife
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it I would
also like to thank Nikki for her photos
from the candidates I will put all of
the links to her social media in the
description below so if you enjoy chess
photography feel free to check out some
of some of our work and yeah that's it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon